this is the difference between react
react native and not exactly a
difference but technically how
everything works when you're writing a
react native project hey everyone
welcome back my name is mehal and in
this video we'll be looking at a very
popular question which you would have
seen a lot of places at that is the
difference between react and react
native in order to understand this
question in order to answer this
question we have to dive deep into how
javascript works so let's go and discuss
that in this video also if you're new
here make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel to receive
daily updates on coding related content
on go down this video is a part of code
dam's t-shirt giveaway program for the
month if you want to take part and win
an amazing goal damn t-shirt all you
have to do is leave a comment on this
video about what you think and that's it
you are eligible if your comment gets a
heart from code damn you will win a
t-shirt for absolutely free okay so
before actually discussing what react
native is and how it works let's
actually understand how javascript
really works right so
you have a browser this is your browser
window whether it's a chrome whether
it's a firefox it does not matter the
thing is
you have a javascript
engine sitting right here so whenever
you write document let's say document or
create element right or document.kit
element or whatever you do that goes to
your javascript engine and then this
javascript engine is supposed to tell
the underlying operating system what
needs to be done on the screen right
what do i mean by that let's say you
create a button let's say you create a
button using javascript on the screen
but on the page you would see on your
browser
the button which appears is technically
rendered by your
browser that is your chrome or whatever
our firefox but
this this work the button rendering is
also done inherently done by the
operating system right there is a layer
of javascript which communicates the
following to the browser right which
communicates the following message to
the operating system right so os is
finally able to draw the pixels the
graphics are disabled to shine those
pixels on the screen that makes this
button appear right so what what is
happening here is that first of all
this document api is provided by the
browser to the javascript world right
and then the browser which renders the
button that button api is provided by
the operating system to the browser
right so this this part here is super
important because you cannot create a
button on the screen without using
document and internally the browser
cannot create a button on the screen
without using some internal operating
system api right so technically what's
happening here is that js accesses an
api exposed by the browser and browser
accesses an api exposed by the operating
system this is how your javascript world
works at the moment so if you are
writing something in the js world that
gets directly called by the operating
system on inside browser using certain
v8 apis right so if you go to your
console and if you try to write document
dot
create element or you know summative
native calls native functions like them
and try to convert them to string
you're gonna see chrome says something
like native code or something like that
why is that because that code is not
invoking another javascript function
that code is invoking some c plus plus
code inside of your browser right which
might invoke some operating system level
code as well so this is the architecture
on how javascript works you might think
that react and react native probably
would have
more in common as a react than
javascript but technically speaking
react and react native have only this
part as common that's it that's that's
just a single word let's just now see
how react
native actually works all right with the
react native let's see what's happening
let's remove let's forget about react
for now right so you have again a js
layer where you are writing you're
technically writing a react code but
you're going to discuss that later then
you have a bridge right and then you
finally have an operating system which
would be an android which would be an
ios which could be which should be
pretty much right so what this react
native is doing
is that it allows you to write certain
javascript which calls certain bridge
level apis
which then calls the os level apis and
if you think about this this is very
very similar to what we discussed how
javascript information works because if
you have a phone let's say if you have
an
ios or android or whatever if you have a
phone like this
it has its own operating system for
operating system calls for drawing these
buttons and stuff right if you want a
button on the screen which is 20 pixels
from the left 30 pixels from the top
you're going to have an operating system
called whether it's java whether it's
swift cut lane whatever right when you
do native programming that is with shift
or content or java your app code gets
compiled so your if this is your app
code this app code is compiled into
something which directly calls these os
level
apis right for drawing a button or doing
xyz whatever so therefore you avoid this
hop
right of calling it via a bridge and
this bridge is technically a bridge
right it's it's a bridge where the
message passing happens i mean you can
technically say that it's it's kind of
similar to a browser in a way
but a browser is a much faster way to
call an os level api compared to a
bridge because a browser does not
serialize and deserialize your commands
for for the operating system right if
you want to say document.createelement
the browser will not serialize this and
send it to an os it will actually call
the os so in that case a browser is kind
of not similar to this but in an
architectural level view this is how it
works you write a js function a js
function is serialized for that js
called serialized and passed via a
bridge to an operating system if
required and then the os runs that and
updates the screen however it wants to
okay so what is the point of react and
react native then let's also cover that
very quickly if you understand react is
nothing but a fancy library for
performing a treatise right that's
that's what reacts us at its core so
react does
a construct of a virtual dom and it is
able to see
if a specific node or a parent node has
changed or not in this case let's say
both of them have lost their children
therefore react would optimally try to
update the ui to this now the way this
happens on the my front is that people
said that this ui can pretty much be
also represented like a react native
tree right a tree like diagram where you
have all the application and buttons and
nested things going on
and
whenever somebody taps the layout change
the trees change and so on so what we do
is on the js level we the ui layer which
we have this ui layer is the react right
so whatever the changes are happening
the changes are communicated via a
bridge which
actually serializes and deserializes
these calls and this architecture is
it's it's going to change with the new
advancements in the activative but at
the moment the way it happens is that
this is a bridge
which actually react
js calls have to pass in order to get to
the os so this ui layer is updated just
like it updates the yak layer on the web
right so this ui layer is pretty much
the same
the same as web right
so you can see this ulef for the tree
dipping is the same as web and this ui
layer is called the react package on npm
right so when you download npm install
react or yarn add react you are adding a
react package
to your project now
this bridge right here and some
associated things as well they come
under a renderer right so you have a
tree you have the technology to give the
ui of certain trees or you know the
changes in certain trees but you still
need to convert this tree
into this thing right it still needs to
understand how the native platform
operates or work and for that you need a
renderer for browsers that renderer is
called as a react dog why because your
dom is also represented as a tree but it
needs the html it needs the button tag
it needs the div tag
it needs all these stacks right in react
native we have the view tag
we have the image tag and so on now
interestingly when you write reactions
for web you directly use the html things
but
because mobiles are not i mean for the
most part they don't have a html like
syntax you still write custom you know
react made elements but these elements
get transpired into native views on
their respective operating system right
so if it's an ios whatever the view
or you know uh analogous to
whatever that did on ios that will
happen on ios and similarly on android
right so
these
this jsx or whatever you're writing
needs a way to transpile into this
native view right and that is where this
renderer comes into place not react on
for this but this is actually called as
the activator when you install react
native package from npm when you say npm
install react native you're actually
installing a raindrop the library is
still reapp this ui layer is still react
this part right here this communication
and the bridge and everything which
happens with the operating system and
even some native files in this case are
provided
by the app network so this is the
difference between react react native
and not exactly a difference but
technically how everything works when
you're writing a react native project so
yeah that's pretty much it for this
video i hope you understood something
new from this one you understood how
react and react native actually work and
even javascript in a lot of cases and
why
sometimes native code might be faster
because you can see you avoid this hop
right i mean sure there are ways to
optimize this and react native as well
so that your message does not cross
bridge a lot of times but maybe that's
for some other video but yeah that's all
for this one if you liked it make sure
you leave a like subscribe to the
channel and hit the bell icon thank you
so much for watching and i'm gonna see
you in the next video
[Music]
you